People with physical illness are often open about discussing their ailments with family, friends, and even sometimes with virtual strangers. But mental illness is often a deep and sometimes shameful secret. People with serious mental illness are feared or even pitied and can face discrimination in nearly every aspect of their lives, from finding jobs to finding housing to getting adequate medical care. Where does this stigma come from and why is it so pervasive? How does stigma affect the lives of people with mental illness? illness and what does the research say about how to fight it? Has the new openness with which some celebrities discuss their mental health struggles made a difference in reducing stigma? Is mental illness less stigmatized than it used to be or is stigma as pervasive as ever? Welcome to
患有躯体疾病的人通常乐于与家人、朋友甚至有时与虚拟陌生人讨论他们的病情。但精神疾病往往是一个深藏不露、有时甚至令人羞耻的秘密。患有严重精神疾病的人会遭到恐惧甚至同情，并可能在生活的几乎方方面面面临歧视，从找工作、找住房到获得充分的医疗护理。这种污名从何而来，为什么如此普遍？污名化如何影响精神疾病患者的生活？研究对于如何消除污名有何见解？一些名人以公开态度讨论其心理健康挣扎的新开放性是否在减少污名方面发挥了作用？精神疾病受到的污名是否比过去少，还是像以前一样无处不在？欢迎来到
Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Patrick Corrigan, a distinguished professor of psychology at the Illinois Institute of Technology. Dr. Corrigan has spent decades studying stigma and mental health and developing anti-stigma intervention programs. He is the editor of APA's journal Stigma and Health and has written more than 400 peer-reviewed articles and authored or edited 15 books. He's also written about living with mental illness himself, and he's part of the team that developed the honest, open, proud series of anti-stigma programs, which we'll talk about with him today. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Corrigan.
《心理学话你知》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是伊利诺伊理工大学（Illinois Institute of Technology）心理学杰出教授帕特里克·科里根（Patrick Corrigan）博士。科里根博士几十年来一直研究污名与心理健康，并开发抗污名干预项目。他是APA期刊《污名与健康》（Stigma and Health）的主编，撰写了400多篇同行评审文章，并撰写或编辑了15本书。他还撰写过关于自己与精神疾病共存的文章，并且是开发“诚实、公开、自豪”（Honest, Open, Proud）系列抗污名项目团队的成员之一，我们今天将与他探讨这些项目。感谢您做客我们的节目，科里根博士。
Thank you for having me. You've been studying mental health stigma for decades. How pervasive is it, and what does the research say about the extent to which people with mental illness are stigmatized in their daily lives? I think if you ask that from an epidemiologic standpoint, it would be a little hard to say what percent of the population. However, looking at it differently, people clearly know the stigma of mental illness is as big a problem as the symptoms themselves. As you said, it adds this notion of shame. I always think this is terrible irony to issues like depression. Not only you have to deal with sadness, you should be ashamed to yourself.
谢谢邀请我。您研究心理健康污名已经几十年了。这种污名有多普遍？研究表明，精神疾病患者在日常生活中受到污名的程度如何？我想如果从流行病学的角度来问这个问题，很难说占人口的百分之多少。然而，从不同的角度来看，人们清楚地知道，精神疾病的污名化就像症状本身一样是一个大问题。正如您所说，它增添了这种羞耻感。我总是认为，像抑郁症这样的问题存在一种可怕的讽刺。你不仅要应对悲伤，你还得为自己感到羞耻。
and the impact on people might be looked at in terms of public stigma, what happens when you're the butt of stereotypes and prejudice or self-stigma, what happens when you internalize it? And we pretty much agree that the stigma of mental illness is the same category as racism and sexism and ageism. And just as that's a priority in American culture, so it falls to mental health and other. their health conditions. So how does stigma prevent people from getting the care that they need? I know that you've written about that.
而对人们的影响可以从公共污名（当你成为刻板印象和偏见的笑柄时会发生什么）或自我污名（当你内化这些污名时会发生什么）的角度来看待。我们基本一致认为，精神疾病的污名与种族主义、性别歧视和年龄歧视属于同一类别。正如这些在美国文化中是优先事项一样，它也落在了精神健康和其他健康状况上。那么，污名是如何阻止人们获得所需治疗的呢？我知道您写过这方面的文章。
Interesting thing about the stigma of mental illness compared to, for example, a stigma of race. So if I'm in a room of 100 people and you're a different color than me, a white man, and I'm a racist, I can tell, I can see it in you. Or if you're a different gender, I can see that in you. You can't tell somebody with mental illness has a mental illness. We might think we can, but in fact, something to consider for the group is something between 25 and 40 percent of the population meet a DSM category for a mental illness. So how do you get the stigma of mental illness?
关于精神疾病的污名，有一个有趣的地方，比如与种族污名相比。所以如果我身处一个有一百人的房间里，而你的肤色和我不同（一个白人），而我是一个种族主义者，我能看出来，我能在你身上看到这一点。或者如果你是不同的性别，我能在你身上看到这一点。你无法看出患有精神疾病的人患有精神疾病。我们可能认为我们能看出来，但事实上，该群体需要考虑的一个数据是，大约25%到40%的人口符合DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）中关于精神疾病的类别。那么你是如何沾染上精神疾病的污名的呢？
You get labeled. You get seen coming out of a psychiatrist's office. Hey, that's here. You're coming out of Dr. Jones' office. He must be nuts. And so people don't want that stigma. So the way they avoid the labels, they don't get to. care. And research suggests whether it's a pretty serious mental illness like schizophrenia or a more
你被贴上了标签。你被看到从精神科医生的办公室走出来。嘿，那是这里。你从琼斯博士的办公室出来。他一定是个疯子。因此人们不希望有这种污名。因此，他们为了避开这些标签，不去寻求治疗。研究表明，无论是像精神分裂症这样相当严重的精神疾病，还是更为
benign experience like a reactive disorder. Up to 40% of people will not seek out care. Part of the reason because of stigma. My sense is that people with mental illness are sometimes blamed for their predicament or that some people believe that mental illnesses are no big deal like depression or anxiety and that people should just be able to snap out of it. Do you see the those attitudes in your work? And if so, how can we overcome them? Well, the first one, perhaps based on the research, is a bit easier. I would say what are the stereotypes about people mental illness? Again, something familiar to people. We know the stereotypes about the LGBTQ community or black citizens. And those
良性的经历（如反应性障碍），高达40%的人不会寻求治疗。部分原因是因为污名。我的感觉是，精神疾病患者有时会因为他们的困境而受到指责，或者有些人认为精神疾病没什么大不了的，就像抑郁症或焦虑症一样，人们应该能够自己走出来。你在工作中见过这些态度吗？如果是这样，我们如何克服它们？嗯，第一点也许基于研究，稍微容易一些。我想说的是，关于精神疾病患者的刻板印象是什么？同样，这也是人们熟悉的。我们了解针对LGBTQ群体或黑人公民的刻板印象。而这些
stereotypes lead to all sorts of discrimination. The stereotypes about people who series mental illness are dangerous. And so you might look good, right? You can snap in any moment. You're going to be violent, so employer's not going to hire you or landlord's not going to rent to you. You're to blame for it. You're incompetence. And sometimes there's this moral component to it. Those are the stereotypes that emerge and the research. What to do about it? Could be the entire remainder of our session. We, over the last 20 years, began our research. We began our research. with what we now realize is a naive assumption that education is the best way to get rid of stigma, that if we educate the public that mental illness is a brain disorder,
刻板印象会导致各种歧视。关于患有严重精神疾病的人的刻板印象是他们很危险。所以你可能看起来不错，对吧？你随时可能崩溃。你会具有暴力倾向，所以雇主不会雇佣你，房东也不会把房子租给你。你要为此负责。你无能。有时这其中还包含道德成分。这些就是在研究中出现的刻板印象。对此该怎么办？这可能是我们余下访谈的全部内容。在过去的20年里，我们开始了我们的研究。我们带着现在意识到是天真的假设开始研究，即教育是消除污名的最佳途径，如果我们教育公众精神疾病是一种脑部疾病，
and we show them pictures of MRIs where the brains are lighting up because they're hallucinating, they'll decrease stigma. And it's true that that decreases blame. If I teach people that mental illness is a genetic disorder, I must likely to blame them. But, But the bigger problem is you also list like they think they're going to get better. They're not going to recover. And so I'm not going to hire you because you can look good now. You can snap in any moment. And so the idea of educating stigma away in the meta-analysis we did in 2015 just is not supported.
并向他们展示MRI（磁共振成像）照片，其中大脑因为幻觉而亮起来，这样就会减少污名。确实，这会减少责备。如果我教导人们精神疾病是一种遗传性疾病，我就不太可能责怪他们。但是，更大的问题是，你还会列举出他们认为自己会好起来的情况。他们不会康复。因此我不会雇佣你，因为你现在看起来很好。你随时可能崩溃。因此，在2015年的元分析中，通过教育消除污名的想法并没有得到支持。
What is supported is there is a social psychologist named Gordon Olport in the 50s who said that one of the ways we got rid of, got rid of. We decreased racial bigotry is contact between white people and black people. And so that led to the contact hypothesis. And what we find pretty much with mental illness is the best way to decrease the stigma of mental illness is to have contact between people with mental illness and the rest of the public as peers. And that kind of contact greatly tears down stigma. Except that people with mental illness are not, they may be reluctant to tell. people that they have a mental illness. And so sort of like gay people 20, 30 years ago, who didn't come out and you didn't know that you had gay people in your family, they were
得到支持的是，50年代有一位名叫戈登·奥尔波特（Gordon Allport）的社会心理学家说过，我们消除（消除）种族偏见的方法之一是白人和黑人之间的接触。这导致了接触假说。我们发现，对于精神疾病，减少精神疾病污名的最好方法是让精神疾病患者与公众的其他成员作为同伴进行接触。这种接触极大地打破了污名。除了精神疾病患者不愿意告诉别人他们患有精神疾病之外。因此，有点像20、30年前的同性恋者，他们没有出柜，你不知道你的家庭里有同性恋者，他们是
your friends and your neighbors, and maybe the same thing is happening right now with people who have mental illness, right? I mean, how do we change that? Amen. So some stigmas are obvious. Racial stigma is mostly obvious. You can tell by skin color. Sexism is mostly obvious. You can tell by body type. Old age is obvious. You can tell by gray hair. You can't pretty much tell the stigma of mental illness. And in that way, it's a lot like the stigma LGBTQ is what's happened in our lifetime is the stigma LGBTQ has changed hugely, improved greatly. And they'll get me wrong, we still got a long way to go.
你的朋友和邻居，也许现在患有精神疾病的人身上也正在发生同样的事情，对吧？我的意思是，我们如何改变这一点？太对了。因此，有些污名是显而易见的。种族污名通常是显而易见的。你可以从肤色看出。性别歧视通常是显而易见的。你可以从体型看出。老年是显而易见的。你可以从白发看出。你基本上看不出精神疾病的污名。从这个意义上说，它很像LGBTQ的污名，在我们的一生中，LGBTQ的污名已经发生了巨大的变化，有了极大的改善。别误会我，我们还有很长的路要走。
But improved greatly because 30, 40, 50 years ago, courageous men and women came out and told their stories. It becomes easier for them as a community arose and it now can do this embedded in other like-minded people. So the same thing is with serious mental illness, the degree to which you come out is the degree to which you'll challenge a stigma. But you're right, there's huge risks to it. And so how to change the world so that people can come out with less risks. In addition to being a researcher, you're also a person with mental illness, and you've talked and written about your experience.
但有了极大的改善，因为30、40、50年前，勇敢的男女们出柜并讲述了他们的故事。随着一个社区的崛起，这变得对他们更容易了，现在他们可以在其他志同道合的人当中做到这一点。严重精神疾病也是如此，你出柜的程度就是你挑战污名的程度。但你是对的，这其中存在巨大的风险。那么如何改变世界，让人们能够以更小的风险出柜呢？除了作为一名研究人员，你也是一名精神疾病患者，你曾谈到并撰写过你的经历。
Could you tell us a little bit about that and how it's affected the way you approach your work? So I've been diagnosed over the last 40-some years, ultimately with bipolar disorder, major depression, generalizing anxiety disorder. I've been on meds. I took them this morning. I've been hospitalized in crises. I know the shame of having me to go to an inpatient unit in that one phone on the wall and call my wife and tell her that I won't be at my daughter Elizabeth's school that night.
你能给我们讲讲这方面的情况吗？以及它是如何影响你对待工作的方式的？我在过去40年里被诊断出患有双相情感障碍、重度抑郁症、广泛性焦虑症。我一直在吃药。我今天早上刚吃过。我曾在危机中住院。我知道去住院部、面对墙上那部唯一的电话、打电话给我妻子告诉她我今晚不能去女儿伊丽莎白的学校时的羞耻感。
And so stigma is not an abstraction to me. It's a reality. And I think stigma efforts should be led by the group of people at lived experience. I'm hugely for gay rights. I am a straight male. My goal is to be an ally to people with lived experience in the gay world and support them. So to beat stigma, it's people with lived experience that should do it. I'm not doctors. I am also a doctor, but my authority in this comes with my own lived experience. There's been a lot of talk about mental health in the news over the past couple of years with
因此，污名对我来说不是一个抽象的概念。这是一个现实。我认为消除污名的努力应该由有一身经历的人群来领导。我非常支持同性恋权利。我是个直男。我的目标是成为同性恋世界中有一身经历的人的盟友并支持他们。因此，要战胜污名，应该由有一身经历的人来做。我不是医生。我也是一名医生，但我在这方面的权威来自于我自己的亲身经历。在过去几年里，新闻中关于心理健康有很多讨论，
celebrities like Naomi Osaka, Simone Biles, discussing their mental health struggles, and then more general discussions about the mental health toll that the pandemic has taken on all of us. So do you think the growing awareness and conversation about mental health is doing anything to reduce stigma now? So the one bit of sobering news is the meta-analysis, a systematic review, we did some years ago, is pretty much finding the stigma is getting worse. and in post-hockeying the data, our best guess is the degree to which dangerousness, violence, mass murders, especially in the United States, are connected to mental illness.
比如名人大阪直美（Naomi Osaka）、西蒙·拜尔斯（Simone Biles）讨论她们的心理健康挣扎，以及更普遍地讨论大流行病给我们所有人的心理健康带来的沉重代价。那么，你认为对心理健康日益增长的觉醒和讨论是否在减少现在的污名方面发挥了作用？一个令人清醒的消息是，我们几年前做的元分析（系统性回顾）发现污名实际上正在恶化。在对数据进行事后分析后，我们最好的猜测是，危险性、暴力、大规模谋杀（尤其是在美国）与精神疾病之间的联系程度。
And so every time there's a mass shooting, I'd frequently end up on the radio to respond to the interviewer that, in fact, people's serious mental illness are not more dangerous, not likely to snap, and not let you go out to shoot people. That's a very compelling story and really keeps a stigma up there. What's changing it are famous people coming out. And that's a good step. And I think some of the people who come out like Simone Biles is very courageous and very important to us. And become a little concerned some of the famous people coming out are doing it more for the PR than actually trying to make a difference.
因此，每次发生大规模枪击事件时，我经常最终会出现在电台回应采访者，即事实上，患有严重精神疾病的人并不更危险，不太可能突然崩溃，也不太可能出去枪杀别人。这是一个非常引人注目的故事，确实使污名持续存在。正在改变这一点的是名人的出柜。这是很好的一步。我认为一些出柜的名人，比如西蒙·拜尔斯，非常勇敢，对我们非常重要。但我开始有点担心，一些出柜的名人这样做更多是为了公关，而不是真正试图做出改变。
But we actually did a research study where we compared the impact of Mariah Carey, who is a person with bipolar disorder, to somebody named Malia, who is, if there's a way of putting it, an average person with bipolar disorder. And what its impact is on the viewer. And Malia had a much bigger impact because when you asked about Mariah, people say, she's just not like me. You know, Mariah is not your typical person with mental illness. So to the listener today, who's going to make the impact, and again, I use this word hesitantly, is the average person with mental health challenges that you sit next to at work, or on the train on the way home, or in your faith-based community, or extended family, the degree to which they come out and tell their stories of recovery,
但我们实际上做了一项研究，我们将患有双相情感障碍的名人玛丽亚·凯莉（Maria Carey）的影响力与一个名叫玛丽亚（Malia）的人进行了比较，如果可以这样形容的话，她是一个患有双相情感障碍的普通人。以及它对观众的影响。玛丽亚（Malia）产生了更大的影响，因为当你问及玛丽亚·凯莉时，人们会说，她和我根本不一样。你知道，玛丽亚·凯莉不是那种典型的精神疾病患者。因此，对于今天的听众来说，将产生影响的——再次说明，我谨慎地使用这个词——是在工作中、在回家的火车上、在你的信仰社区或大家庭中坐在你身边的、有心理健康挑战的普通人，他们出柜并讲述他们康复故事的程度，
which, again, we need to marine people as a reality. And the other problem, the other big source of stigma is mental health psychiatry and psychology itself. I mean, when I was a student, I learned schizophrenia was a kiss of death diagnosis, and the best thing you could ever happen is you live on the back ward of a hospital. And the reality to that from long-term follow-up research for schizophrenia, which is the prototypic bad mental illness, is a rule of thirds. If you follow them for 10 to 20 years, about one third will get over it like a respiratory disorder. About one third will have to manage it like a tough case of diabetes. Watch your lifestyle, take your meds, talk to health care providers. About one third of those people is what we think of with people, serious mental illness.
再次说明，我们需要将人们作为现实来重塑。另一个问题，污名的另一个主要来源是心理健康精神病学和心理学本身。我的意思是，当我还是个学生的时候，我了解到精神分裂症是死亡之吻的诊断，你可能遇到的最好的事情就是住在医院的后病房。而从针对精神分裂症（作为典型的严重精神疾病）的长期随访研究来看，现实是三分之一法则。如果你跟踪他们10到20年，大约三分之一的人会像呼吸道疾病一样康复。大约三分之一的人必须像处理棘手的糖尿病病例一样去管理它。注意生活方式，吃药，与医护人员沟通。大约三分之二的人是我们认为患有严重精神疾病的人。
And about two thirds of them will do just fine if there's rehabilitation programs, state-of-the-out rehabilitation programs available. So recovery is a reality. and that really is the messes that changes things. And the way your average next door neighbor shares that with you is the biggest source of changing stigma. And yet that's probably one of the biggest hurdles
如果有康复项目、最先进的康复项目可用，其中大约三分之二的人会做得很好。因此，康复是一个现实。这确实是改变事物的关键信息。你隔壁的普通邻居与你分享这一点的方式是改变污名的最大来源。然而，这可能是最大的障碍之一，
because I think it's not generally understood by the public that you can recover from or live a reasonable life with a serious mental illness such as schizophrenia. Again, going back to the LGBT world, I grew up in a time that I reluctantly say this, that gay people were looked at as sick perverts. And there's almost no educational way to challenge that. It's actually meeting gay, lesbians, bisexual people as peers.
因为我认为公众普遍不理解，你可以从精神分裂症等严重精神疾病中康复或过上合理的生活。再次回到LGBT世界，我在一个我勉强说出口的时代长大，当时同性恋者被视为有病的变态。几乎没有什么教育方法可以挑战这一点。这实际上是作为同伴遇到同性恋、女同性恋、双性恋的人。
That that tears down the stereotype. You know, you're not a sick pervert. And the more gay people you meet, the more it colors the picture differently and it changes stigma. So recovery is a reality, but people aren't going to believe it. I mean, they don't believe we're in the middle of COVID in need a vaccine. What will change it is somebody who says, hey, you know, I had a history of bipolar disorder. I was hospitalized. And despite that, despite the key word, despite that, I'm able to go to school, get a job, be independent, have 2.3 children, and have a good life.
这打破了刻板印象。你知道，你不是一个有病的变态。你遇到的同性恋越多，它就越能以不同的方式为主题着色，并改变污名。因此，康复是一个现实，但人们不会相信。我的意思是，他们不相信我们正处于新冠疫情之中并且需要疫苗。将改变这一切的是那些说，“嘿，你知道，我有双相情感障碍病史。我曾住院。尽管如此，尽管有这个关键词，我还是能够上学、找到工作、独立、有2.3个孩子并过上好生活”的人。
So I want to talk about the role of language in perpetuating stigma. I mean, you just used a word that was used commonly around LGBT people, that they were perverts. And a lot of people use words like crazy or insane very casually. And, I mean, police are constantly saying that, well, this person who shot up that school is crazy. But I think we really need to rethink the way that we use words because they can perpetuate stigma. At APA, we're aware of the power of stigmatizing words, and we recently changed the name of our Journal of Abnormal Psychology to the Journal of Psychopathology and Clinical Science. How important is language in stigmatizing and destigmatizing mental illness?
所以我想谈谈语言在延续污名中的作用。我的意思是，你刚刚用了一个常用于LGBT人群的词，说他们是变态。很多人非常随意地使用“疯狂”或“精神失常”之类的词。而且，我的意思是，警察经常说，好吧，那个枪击学校的人疯了。但我认为我们真的需要重新审视我们使用语言的方式，因为它们会延续污名。在APA，我们意识到污名化语言的力量，我们最近将我们的《异常心理学期刊》（Journal of Abnormal Psychology）更名为《精神病理学与临床科学期刊》（Journal of Psychopathology and Clinical Science）。语言在污名化和去污名化精神疾病方面有多重要？
Well, I'm going to surprise you because as a focus, I think people put too much energy in it. Let's be clear, the N-word is totally intolerable. such that people that are white like you and me can't even say it and shouldn't. And you may know by act of Congress, the MR word has now been replaced by intellectual disability. So the MR word is probably the closest thing in behavioral health to an N word. But separate from that, there are no real clear N words in mental health. For example, there's a big debate on whether we should say mental illness. And I actually talk a lot publicly, and I talked about the challenges of mental illness.
嗯，我要让你感到惊讶，因为作为一个焦点，我认为人们在这上面投入了太多的精力。让我们明确一点，N开头的词（指黑鬼）是完全不能容忍的。以至于像你我这样的白人甚至不能说，也不应该说。你可能知道通过国会法案，MR开头的词（指智障）现在已经被“智力残疾”所取代。因此，MR这个词可能是行为健康中最接近N开头的词。但除此之外，心理健康中没有真正明确的N开头的词。例如，关于我们是否应该说精神疾病，存在着巨大的争论。我实际上在公共场合做了很多演讲，我谈到了精神疾病的挑战。
I'm sorry, I talked about the harm of mental health challenges. And somebody came up and buttonholed me and said, I have a mental illness. Don't decrease it. I want to be respectful if I'm talking to a group and they want to handle things in a certain way. Okay. There is a group called Schizophrenics Anonymous, which nowadays seemsly, a little awkward, but they're still around and have a big presence. But here's the bigger issue with language is it leads to word police, which can be pretty prominent in mental illness.
我很抱歉，我之前谈过心理健康挑战带来的危害。然后有人走过来拉住我说：“我有精神疾病，别把它说得无足轻重。”如果我在对一个群体说话，而他们希望以某种特定方式处理事情，我希望保持尊重。好吧。有一个叫“精神分裂症匿名互助会”的组织，现在听起来可能有点尴尬，但他们仍然存在，而且很有影响力。但这里关于语言的一个更大的问题是，它催生了词语警察，这在精神疾病领域相当突出。
And I consulted with a group in Colorado once about stigma, and they had met for three months before I got there, and they were still fighting amongst themselves on whether they're stigma of mental illness, stigma of mental health challenges, the prejudice of mental illness, and we, the advocates, the progressives, we don't need to fight among ourselves about this because we're not trying to change our ideas. We're trying to change the average person. My aunt Lillian, who worked at Walmart, we're trying to change her idea. And she doesn't know this mental health challenges versus mental illness thing.
我曾经在科罗拉多州就污名化问题咨询过一个小组，在我到达之前他们已经开了三个月会，而且他们仍在争论到底是“精神疾病的污名化”、“心理健康挑战的污名化”、还是“精神疾病的偏见”。而我们，倡导者、进步人士，不需要为这些争吵，因为我们不是在试图改变我们自己的想法。我们试图改变的是普通人。我姑妈莉莲（Lillian）在沃尔玛工作，我们试图改变她的想法。她并不懂什么心理健康挑战与精神疾病的区别。
She doesn't understand the journal of abnormal psychology. So, yes, we should be careful about language. I ask people to go back and listen to what I'm saying now. I always use person first language. I agree with that. However, we need to be careful on a degree to which we punch this because some people reduce that to, well, all we need to do is change the words and we're fine. And that's not going to do it at all.
她看不懂《异常心理学杂志》。所以，是的，我们在语言上应该谨慎。我请大家回听我现在说的话。我一直使用以人为本的语言。我同意这一点。然而，我们需要注意我们在这上面强调的程度，因为有些人把它简化为：“嗯，我们只需要改改词就没事了。”这根本解决不了问题。
It clearly did not happen. We went from Negro to colored to African-American. And so it's not going to happen in the mental health side. So that raises the question. of what does work, and I know you've been involved in anti-stigma campaigns. You make the case that a lot of public education campaigns that try to educate people about mental illness don't really reduce stigma and can backfire. Why is that? Well, as I said before, interestingly enough, George H.W. Bush, I think around 1990, had National Institute of Mental Health
这显然没有发生。我们从“黑人（Negro）”到“有色人种（colored）”再到“非裔美国人（African-American）”。所以这在心理健康方面也不会发生。这就提出了一个问题：什么才管用？我知道你参与过反污名化运动。你提出这样一个观点：许多试图向人们普及精神疾病知识的公众教育活动，并没有真正减少污名化，反而可能会适得其反。为什么会这样？嗯，正如我之前所说，很有意思的是，老乔治·H·W·布什（George H.W. Bush），我想大概在1990年左右，让国家心理健康研究所
launched the decade of the brain. And in part, there was a justifiable point that. I mean, was still a bit of a new idea that a lot of mental illness is the result of brain disorders. And so they would show pictures of brains that were diseased and say, see, this is a biological problem. But that doesn't change attitudes about whether the person's really different than me. You're broken. Now I can see it here. And I don't want to be with broken people. And so this attempt to reduce mental illness to a brain disorder or genetic disorder or inevitable
发起了“脑的十年”。在某种程度上，这有一个合理的出发点。我的意思是，认为许多精神疾病是脑部紊乱的结果，这在当时仍然是一个有点新颖的想法。因此，他们会展示患病大脑的照片，并说：“看，这是一个生物学问题。”但这并没有改变人们关于“这个人是否真的与我不同”的态度。你坏掉了。现在我在这里看到了。我不想和坏掉的人在一起。因此，这种试图将精神疾病简化为脑部紊乱、基因紊乱或不可避免的
inheritance does not change stigma. So what campaigns and messages actually have been shown to help reduce stigma? So most major Western countries in the world other than the U.S. have done nationwide anti-stigma programs. And most have come to the conclusion that educational programs don't work. Contact does work. How the heck do you do contact? And most of them support grassroots organizations where people live experience, go talk to their peers about their life experience.
遗传的尝试，并没有消除污名化。那么，到底有哪些运动和信息被证明有助于减少污名化呢？因此，除美国外，世界上大多数主要的西方国家都开展了全国性的反污名化项目。大多数国家得出的结论是，教育项目不管用。接触（Contact）才管用。到底怎么做才叫接触？他们大多数人都支持草根组织，让有生活经验的人去和同龄人谈论他们的生活经验。
So in Canada, they would hire people in Calgary with mental illness to go to community groups, Kowanas to talk to the community leaders about mental illness stigma in order to change it. So we believe, again, using LGBTQ as an example, I think one of the ways we got to gay marriage is more and more and more gay people came out. And it first challenges the stigma of only a weird set of small group of people have LGBTQ because it's not case. There's a lot of people LGBTQ. And as that group increased, it just physically suppresses bigotry. I mean, if I'm a gay bigot, I'm less likely to do it, at least in a large city where there's gay neighborhoods and say bad things. And so mental illness is the same thing. The more people, mental illness
所以在加拿大，他们会雇用卡尔加里患有精神疾病的人去社区组织，比如基瓦尼斯俱乐部（Kiwanis），向社区领袖谈论精神疾病的污名化，以改变它。所以我们相信，再次以LGBTQ为例，我认为我们走向同性恋婚姻的途径之一，是越来越多的同性恋者出柜了。这首先挑战了一种污名，即只有一小撮怪异的人群才有LGBTQ，因为事实并非如此。有很多LGBTQ人群。随着这个群体的增加，它自然就在物理上压制了盲目偏见。我的意思是，如果我是一个同性恋偏见者，我不太可能表现出来，至少在大城市里，那里有同性恋社区，人们不会说坏话。因此，精神疾病也是如此。越多的人，精神疾病
come out, the more it will suppress bigotry and it will promote what we would call affirming attitudes. And there's two affirming attitudes. One is the reality people of mental illness do recover. And two, therefore, they should have hopes and aspirations just like everybody do. So how useful are allies? Because you talk about the LGBTQ population, which we don't know exactly how big it is, but there are many more mentally ill people in the world, I would argue, than there are LGBTQ people. So how can allies participate, help, and be effective? Because they don't necessarily have the lived experience. So if you want to go with population research and anybody who's listening to those statistics, they lie. LGBTQ, depending on you're looking at, it's about
出柜，它就越能压制偏见，并促进我们所说的肯定性态度（affirming attitudes）。这里有两种肯定性态度。一是患有精神疾病的人确实会康复这一现实。二是因此，他们应该和所有人一样拥有希望和抱负。那么盟友有多大用处呢？因为你谈到了LGBTQ人群，虽然我们不知道它确切有多大，但我可以说，世界上精神疾病患者的数量肯定比LGBTQ人群多得多。那么盟友如何参与、提供帮助并发挥有效作用呢？因为他们不一定有亲身经历。如果你想参考人口研究，任何听这些统计数据的人都会发现它们在撒谎。LGBTQ，取决于你看的数据，大约占人口的
10 to 15 percent of population. People with mental illness according to DSM is about 40 percent. So you're right, a lot more of us. And people are going to sit there and they're going to say, no way. And that's because people, mental illness, are in the closet, just like gay people usually be in the closet. Or they're not diagnosed. Or they're not diagnosed, though I want to be careful with that because that might suggest the more we diagnose people, the less will decrease stigma. And again, I think stigma is fundamentally a social construction, not a medical one. There are a lot more of us with mental illness, and the more we come out, the better. Allies are good. again, for the LGBTQ community, there is a group, I think, called P flag, which are parents
10%到15%。根据《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM），患有精神疾病的人大约占40%。所以你是对的，我们当中有更多的人。人们会坐在那里说：“不可能。”这是因为患有精神疾病的人在隐瞒，就像同性恋者过去常常隐瞒一样。或者他们没有被诊断出来。或者他们没有被诊断出来，虽然我想对此保持谨慎，因为这可能暗示我们诊断越多的人，消除的污名化就越少。再说一次，我认为污名化从根本上说是一个社会构建，而不是一个医学构建。我们当中有更多的人患有精神疾病，我们越是出柜，情况就会越好。盟友很好。再次以LGBTQ社群为例，有一个组织，我想叫做P flag，也就是女同性恋和男同性恋的父母、家人和朋友
family and friends of lesbians and gays. There you go. Which is allies. And that's good. They need to support. But in no way can we say the only reason why tearing down the stigma of gay makes sense is because they have parents, friends, and allies. The parents, friends, and allies are there to support.
就是这个。这就是盟友。这很好。他们需要支持。但我们绝不能说，打破对同性恋的污名化之所以有意义，仅仅是因为他们有父母、朋友和盟友。父母、朋友和盟友的存在是为了支持
the agenda of persons that are gay. Also, they're there to support the notion that Mr. gay individual, your job is not to pass as straight. Your job is to live as a gay person and me as an ally to support you where you are. I think allies is even a bigger deal in mental health, partly because the stigma as people of mental illness are broken and they They don't know any better and they need doctors to tell them what to do. And so generally, discussions about mental health are led by people in white coats. And so the message here is no, you're an ally. You can help the person with lived experience push the agenda, but their voice needs to be first.
同性恋人群的诉求。同样，他们的存在也是为了支持这样一种观念：同性恋朋友，你的工作不是假装成异性恋。你的工作是作为同性恋者生活，而我作为盟友在你的立场上支持你。我认为在心理健康领域，盟友甚至更加重要，部分原因在于人们对精神疾病患者的污名化是他们坏掉了，他们不懂事，需要医生来告诉他们该怎么做。因此，总的来说，关于心理健康的讨论都是由穿白大褂的人主导的。这里的讯息是：不，你是一个盟友。你可以帮助有亲身经历的人推动诉求，但他们的声音必须是第一位的。
Do you see generational differences in the level of stigma? there's often a lot of talk about how millennials and Gen Z and Gen X that they're more open to the idea of, first of all, treating mental health like you would treat your physical health and that maybe they don't see it as being such a shameful thing. Well, my first response to anything like that is we definitely have to do the research. However, anecdotally, I think yes. I think one of the ways my own personal history is, again, I grew up in a very gay, phobic time. And my kids, when we went to high school, escaped all of that. They didn't
你看到不同代际之间在污名化程度上的差异了吗？人们经常谈论千禧一代、Z世代和X世代对以下观念更加开放：首先，像对待身体健康一样对待心理健康，也许他们不认为这是一件那么耻辱的事情。嗯，我对任何类似事情的第一个反应是，我们绝对必须进行研究。然而，从轶事来看，我认为是的。我认为我个人经历的方式之一是，我成长在一个对同性恋非常恐惧的时代。我的孩子们，当我们去高中时，摆脱了这一切。他们不
understand what the big deal was. They had gay flags. They had gay groups. And they had personal gay friends. They have a gay uncle. They have a gay minister. And they just didn't get it. And so I believe the current high school and college students are someone in that position right now. They don't get it. Why do I have to keep it a secret? And we have an anti-stigma program that we present to people with mental illness. And they're like, yeah, I'm going to come out and disclose. What's the big deal? So I hope there's a cohort effect. That said, we always need to be careful because we would hope there's a cohort effect against racism. And yet, none of us should think we've gotten rid of racism. And so there are still segments of the population that tend to,
明白这有什么大不了的。他们有同性恋旗帜。他们有同性恋组织。他们有同性恋的个人朋友。他们有一个同性恋叔叔。他们有一个同性恋牧师。他们就是不明白。所以我相信目前的高中和大学生现在就处于某种这样的位置。他们不明白。为什么我必须保密？我们有一个反污名化项目，向精神疾病患者展示。他们会觉得：“太好了，我要出柜并公开。这有什么大不了的？”所以我希望有一种同龄群体效应（cohort effect）。话虽如此，我们总是需要谨慎，因为我们希望针对种族主义也有同龄群体效应。然而，我们没有人应该认为我们已经根除了种族主义。因此，人口中仍然有一些群体倾向于
to be unresponsive to whatever their cohorts doing. I mentioned in the introduction that one of your projects is the honest, open, proud, anti-stigma program. Can you tell the listeners what that is and how it works? So if I believe the way you deal with public stigma, with public bigotry, is have more people come out. And if I believe the way you deal with self-stigma, the shame is strategically to come out, They're not as open proud as a program to help people with mental illness decide when and where and how they want to come out with their mental health challenges. Three lessons. First lessons consider the pros and cons of coming out, which by the way vary depending on when you're talking about coming out at work versus your extended family versus your faith-based community. The second lesson is ways to learn to strategically come out.
对同龄人的做法没有反应。我在引言中提到，你的其中一个项目是“诚实、公开、自豪”反污名化项目。你能告诉听众那是什么以及它是如何运作的吗？因此，如果我认为应对公众污名化、公众偏见的方式是让更多的人出柜；如果我认为应对自我污名化和羞耻感的方式是有策略地出柜，“诚实、公开、自豪”是一个旨在帮助精神疾病患者决定何时、何地以及如何带着他们的心理健康挑战出柜的项目。三个课程。第一课考虑出柜的利弊，顺便说一句，这会根据你谈论的是在工作场所出柜、向大家庭出柜还是向你的信仰社群出柜而有所不同。第二课是学习如何有策略地出柜。
So I'm a person with mental illness. I work next to you in the office, Kim. You seem to be. be a nice person. I take you to Starbucks. I said, do you ever see this movie called Silver Linens Playbook? I don't remember that movie. Well, it's this thing with Bradley Cooper and Jennifer Lawrence and he has bipolar disorder. What do you think? And if you said, I'm sick and tired of Hollywood showing those crazy people, you're probably not a good person for me to come out to. So I can test generically your attitudes about mental illness before I give mine own story. And then the third task is it's your story. What are you going to say? And how do people access this program?
所以，我是个精神疾病患者。我就在办公室的隔壁工位工作，金（Kim）。你看起来是个好人。我带你去星巴克。我说：“你见过一部叫《乌云背后的幸福线》的电影吗？”“我不记得那部电影了。”“哦，就是布莱德利·库珀（Bradley Cooper）和詹妮弗·劳伦斯（Jennifer Lawrence）演的那个，他有双相情感障碍。你怎么看？”如果你说：“我厌倦了好莱坞展示那些疯子，”你可能就不是我适合出柜的对象。所以我可以在讲我自己的故事之前，先笼统地试探你对精神疾病的态度。然后第三个任务是，这是你的故事。你要说些什么？人们如何参与这个项目？
If you go to www.hopprogram.org, you can download on the program for free. Program varies depending on who the group is. It was originally developed for my strong suit, which was adults with serious mental illness. My students said, this don't play for us. So we adapted it for college students. It has a section on social media. Do you come out and how do you come out? We're not prescriptive on anything.
如果你访问www.hopprogram.org，你可以免费下载这个项目。项目内容会根据群体不同而有所调整。它最初是为我的强项开发的，也就是严重精神疾病成年人。我的学生说：“这对我们不管用。”所以我们为大学生进行了改编。它有一个关于社交媒体的部分。你是否出柜以及如何出柜？我们在任何事情上都不是教条式的。
We don't tell you whether we should or should not come out online. We tell you the pros and cons and you take it with peers and you can discuss it with them. There's a version for youth. There's a version for college students. There's a version for high school students. The big difference there is legality, whether they're adults or not, a version for veterans. and it's been translated and transposed to about 12 different cultures around the world. So what's next for you, research-wise?
我们不会告诉你是否应该在网上出柜。我们告诉你利弊，你可以和同伴一起拿主意，并与他们讨论。有一个针对青少年的版本。有一个针对大学生的版本。有一个针对高中生的版本。它们之间最大的区别在于法律层面，即他们是否是成年人，还有一个针对退伍军人的版本。它已被翻译并改编为全球大约12种不同的文化。那么你接下来在研究方面有什么计划？
What are you working on? So honest, open-proud is still the base of what we believe. Again, using the LGBTQ community. And what we think was really a strong social movement, the more people, mental illness come out and find like-minded people, and start communities of support like gay areas. Chicago has a Boys Town. The one of that's going to make a big difference.
你在研究什么？所以，“诚实、公开、自豪”仍然是我们信念的基础。再次以LGBTQ社群为例。我们认为真正强大的社会运动是：越多的人、精神疾病患者出柜，找到志同道合的人，并开始建立支持社区，就像同性恋社区一样。芝加哥有一个男孩镇（Boys Town）。这将会带来巨大的改变。
It's already happening. There are groups called Mad Nation, Mad Pride. They're already out there. We started extending it to other groups. So we are now interested in the stigma of substance use disorder, which we find is socially and legally quite different than mental illness. whether you stigmatize people with mental illness, the law protects them. Not so with substance use disorder.
这已经在发生了。有一些名为“疯子国度（Mad Nation）”、“疯子骄傲（Mad Pride）”的组织。他们已经存在了。我们开始将其扩展到其他群体。所以我们现在对物质使用障碍的污名化感兴趣，我们发现它在社会和法律上与精神疾病有很大不同。如果你污名化精神疾病患者，法律会保护他们。物质使用障碍则不然。
You could criminally be arrested for certain substance use disorders. You could civilly be in trouble. The American with Disabilities Act does not protect somebody who's in relapse from substance use disorder. We've also moved one of my colleagues, Lindsay Sheehan, has moved to honest, open proud for people who've attempted suicide. I always like to tell my students' suicide is the atomic bomb of mental health. When a patient tells me their suicidal, everything kicks in. I take over, I stop listening to them. I just go through my protocol and I get them hospitalized. So the experience of suicide is
你可能会因为某些物质使用障碍而被刑事逮捕。你在民事上可能会有麻烦。《美国残疾人法案》不保护处于物质使用障碍复发中的人。我们也采取了行动，我的同事林赛·希恩（Lindsay Sheehan）将“诚实、公开、自豪”推广到了尝试过自杀的人群中。我总是喜欢告诉我的学生，自杀是心理健康的原子弹。当一个病人告诉我他们有自杀倾向时，所有的机制都启动了。我接管局面，我不再听他们说话。我只是走我的流程，然后让他们住院。所以自杀的经历是
really different than the experience of serious mental illness. So how to deal with the stigma of suicide in that life. And then we're working with a colleague on fetal alcohol spectrum disorder to remind people, if you don't know if you're pregnant, you should not drink alcohol. Actually, oversimplify it. Alcohol is a grotesque poison compared to almost anything else. And so that leads to significant developmental disorders, actually to a degree greater than the presence of autism. And the problem is it makes natural sense. What's wrong with you? How could you drink?
真的很严重，不同于严重精神疾病的经历。所以如何应对这种生活中的自杀污名化。然后我们正与一位同事合作开展胎儿酒精谱系障碍（FASD）的研究，提醒人们，如果你不知道自己是否怀孕，就不应该喝酒。实际上，简单过头了。与几乎所有其他东西相比，酒精是一种极其可怕的毒药。因此，这会导致显著的发育障碍，其程度甚至超过了自闭症的存在。问题在于它合乎情理：“你怎么了？你怎么能喝酒？”
What are you a gutter snake? And the problem with that is the more you call these women who drank alcohol while they're pregnant bad words, the more you drive them in the closet, the more we ignore the fact that there are aspects of substance abuse disorder that do not simply reduce to an issue of choice. there's this being disrespectful of them. But the big issue is, and we're doing research on this right now, is stigma is quite present in FASD and mothers don't want to go see pediatricians about it because they don't want to be scolded for it. So generally FASD is better treated the earlier you get it. But if they feel like the pediatrician is going to discipline them for it,
“你是什么沟渠里的蛇吗？”这其中的问题在于，你越是用恶毒的词汇去称呼这些在怀孕期间喝酒的女性，你就越是把她们逼向隐蔽的角落，我们就越是忽视这样一个事实：物质滥用障碍的某些方面并不能简单地归结为选择问题。这是一种对她们的不尊重。但最大的问题是——我们现在正在对此进行研究——FASD中的污名化非常严重，母亲们不想因为这个去看儿科医生，因为她们不想为此受到责备。所以通常情况下，越早治疗FASD效果越好。但如果她们觉得儿科医生会因此训斥她们，
they're not going to go. And that's a stigma issue. Well, Dr. Corrigan, I think you've given our listeners a lot of good advice, a lot of information that I hope that they can use. We'll have some links in our show notes that will help them find your program. And I appreciate you're taking the time to talk to me today. Thank you. Thanks for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeatingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you're listening on Apple Podcasts and you like what you hear,
她们就不会去了。这是一个污名化的问题。好吧，科里根博士（Dr. Corrigan），我认为你为我们的听众提供了很多好的建议、很多我希望他们能用得上的信息。我们将在节目介绍中附上一些链接，帮助他们找到你的项目。我很感激你今天花时间跟我交谈。谢谢。谢谢邀请我。你可以在我们的网站www.combeatingof psychology.org上，或者在Apple、Stitcher、Spotify或你获取播客的任何地方找到往期的《心理学谈话》节目。如果你在Apple Podcasts上收听并且喜欢你所听到的内容，
please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请给我们留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件至speaking of psychology at APA.org。本期《心理学谈话》由李·维纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔迪扬（Chris Condyenne）。谢谢收听。我是来自美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。